Prince Harry hasn't made it to court but
we know he's followed proceedings
closely as he accuses the sun and the
News of the World of phone hacking other
senior Royals were targeted at the time
and to that Harry's released more
sensitive emails from the palace to the
papers Executives Rebecca Brooks and
Robert Thompson they show how much the
late Queen was involved
in July 2017 Sally Osman the Queen's
head of communications emails them
confidentially with the Queen's full
Authority and knowledge of the scale and
effect of hacking and surveillance on
her family
the family wants an apology
in December Sally emails about that
unfinished business I do hope that we
can reach an understanding that resets
the relationship she says adding the
queen is aware that we have spoken
but the palace hears nothing in March
2018 Sally emails I was somewhat
disappointed not to receive an
acknowledgment let alone a reply she
says frustrations increasing by the lack
of response or willingness to engage
Sally threatens legal action but there's
no movement and in May she emails the
growing concern our request is not being
taken seriously
but Prince Harry is serious with this
legal action along with the actor Hugh
Grant who alleges phone hacking blagging
and even burglaries to order they're
fighting for a trial with the tabloids
if it goes to trial that will be a a
significant departure from from what is
up until now be the norm for the royal
family not to go into the witness box
with Fanfare the rest of the family are
preparing for the coronation the king
presenting new military standards and
colors
and the prince and princess of Wales
dropping in on the Brecken beacons it
feels a world away from Harry's court
case Williams settled but his brother
still has a long way to go Laura bundock
Sky News